hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where i do sort of bad
unboxings because my apartment is too
small
to even fit a desk other than this one
which i
cannot fit a playstation 5 on which is
what
is in this box i'm very excited i was
worried it wasn't gonna arrive today
um but it arrived at like 10 a.m
so let's just open up the the brown part
don't have to make this glamorous
um unsurprisingly it's it's just
cardboard but i opened the box and then
i saw the
the jewel sense and now i'm really
excited
oh my gosh uh yeah i got this from best
buy technically
and i did decide to get the disc version
as well for the record so that is what i
am unboxing today inside this box i can
see the front of it
should i show you guys in front of it i
feel like i should the one
the only of i don't know thousands so
not really
playstation 5. it's actually not that
heavy
you know i thought it would be worse
it's a pretty big box
um i'm very curious to see how big this
playstation
actually is because i feel like every
time i see it i'm like oh my gosh that
thing is
huge which for the record i don't know
how it's going to look in my cabinet
we'll have to figure that out but i'm
not actually upset about if it needed to
be this big
to have the best airflow to not sound
like a jet engine
to run pretty video games i will take it
okay oh it's lighting up
come on buddy box
number three okay this one
just has a little playstation logo on
the front
very sleek very nice it is still so
weird to me even though like i use the
death stranding playstation pro that is
my like primary
playstation um which is white with black
hand prints on it it is very weird to
have
the base console for a playstation
console being white it's
i feel like it's so it's just so new
such a fresh take
this is gonna be like a tray situation
these ones are always very difficult on
this chair
i'll be honest alrighty okay okay okay
tray part one yep
i wonder how much watching me unboxing
stresses people out since
like i clearly don't have the capacity
for it here we have
the jewel sense this is my first time
touching it
it feels very different
the thumbsticks i feel like have the
same texture
and there's definitely
some resistance to these triggers but
i'm very excited about the stuff that
this uh
controller can do as far as like the the
feedback is concerned
this feels very different a much bigger
jump between
the dual shock and this than there are
from the um xbox one controller and the
xbox series x controller for sure yeah
okay so hard to give an impression on a
controller until you've played
100 hours with it though a power cable
you love to see it this is going to be
my usbc
controller charger very nice very nice
very nice
i guess it also comes with uh
a this is a quick start guide and also
a safety guide very nice there's another
little latch thing in here
what is this oh okay
okay more bits this is the stand
that's neat so that i guess is your uh
stand i'm gonna have to lay mine
sideways so we'll have to figure out how
that setup works but it's not going to
stand vertical
in that cabinet under any circumstances
okay that's box one done
i think that all that's left is going to
be the console itself so let me just put
this on the ground
cool oh my gosh i'm really excited
this is like i don't know i don't know i
don't know
why but something about like you know
having the ps5 um obviously i've had the
series x for over a month
actually feels like the launch of
next-gen so let's just show you what it
looks like in the packaging
okay okay okay open it up hello big boy
oh okay okay
it's so big it is
lighter than i expected for sure i just
smacked myself in the face so
definitely lighter than i expected is it
bigger than i expected
i'll show it to you guys first so
it looks like a big old sheet of paper
look at the size of my face for scale
i have a large face back side is
pretty pretty sleek this is the actual
back of the thing
and then the front here is where she
gets all her curves from
ah do i feel like this is bigger than i
expected
yes yeah it is it is taller than both of
my towers
which i would not have expected in a
console um
obviously way slimmer and uh
not as long but um
hmm i've just realized like a content
creation
issue that's going to occur with like
where am i going to put it on my pc
setup when i'm streaming
i guess i'll have to put it on the
ground like like i have my pc towers
probably
um yeah i you know what i do like it
like
i find it charming i don't know
does that sound absurd i find it
something about it is charming like i
feel like i'm going to give it a
nickname and when i come home i'm going
to address it as though it is my son
you're having a good day yeah
are you just hanging out here yeah so
how does the stand work is my next
question
um that's an interesting design so i
feel like this is going to slot
just slot in the side like that i might
have it on the wrong way but you get the
idea
um and then it will sit
like that i think i do have it the wrong
side up right now but
that actually is the stand is actually
pretty cool it just like slides
on and off so there you go you guys
the playstation 5. um obviously they're
out for everyone right now you know
i bought mine um every save as everyone
else
and i am going to be streaming demon
souls
tonight which i'm really excited about
and then i thought that i might do like
a series of
miles morales gameplays because that has
been one of my most anticipated titles
of the year um
all year he's holding it like it's a
baby
but i guess that's it for me today
everyone unboxings are always pretty
quick especially when it's a cod soul it
doesn't have that much to come with it
but i am
so excited to try this out which i guess
you will see technically for the first
time
when we stream demon souls later tonight
thank you all for watching i will see
you guys next time bye